I'd like to say a few words for Alec
Guinness first of all he's English
he was born April 2nd 1950 it shows you
what kind of a character actor he is his
first professional appearance was on the
stage 20 years later on his birthday
April 2nd he was discovered by John
Gielgud and he worked at the Old Vic and
he did Hamlet amongst the score of other
stage performances he went into the
service and served in the Second World
War and he came out and he created and
adapted himself Charles Dickens great
expectations and performed Herbert
pocket on the stage on the West End
David Lean saw the performance and cast
him in his first film which was great
expectations
followed by Oliver Twist and of course
the Lavender Hill mob Kind Hearts and
Coronets The Ladykillers the horse's
mouth the bridge on the river kwai it
was my great privilege to view half of
his films in the last couple weeks and
to watch his work is to be a student of
him
he is a painter actor he is what I think
all actors strive to be at rehearsal
yesterday I met him for the first time
and I like a fool asked him what his
favorite performances were and he looked
at me like an interviewer like looking
at an interviewer who didn't have an
appointment and he said I don't have any
favorites I wish the hell I didn't make
any of them I think if you're an actor
you know what he's talking about I think
that dissatisfaction with his work is
part of the things that has made him
strive and find new faces I think it was
Laurence Olivier who once said the best
of us have only five characters running
around inside of his Alec Guinness has
proven that otherwise it's a great great
honor to introduce him and give him this
Lifetime Achievement Award I know of no
other film actor in the history of film
who has touched this man's work and it
is a great tribute to introduce him to
you - to Herbert pocket to mr. Feigin -
those kernels Jacques Sinclair and the
characters that he played in the other
films - yevgraf Avago to Ebenezer
Scrooge - the entire Des Moines family -
the professor in The Ladykillers -
Benedict Boniface - Charles the first
that's amongst 13 of 39 films that he
has done he has a few more in him I love
his work I hope that you'll join and
welcome him Alec Guinness
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
and thank you mr. Hoffman from your over
generous words and all that deep
research work you did it's five weeks
ago that I had a telegram from the
Academy telling me they were doing me
this great honor so I've had the time to
recover from the shock but I don't think
I will ever have time to get over my
amazement and my delight there isn't
time for me to thank everyone directors
writers fellow actors who've made my
life such a happy one including those
wonderful Hollywood stars who were my
heroes when I was a youth you know when
I was a drama student forty-seven years
ago I think they used to be a formidable
lady who came to take classes of what
she called film technique and she
arrived with a large wooden frame about
four foot square which she placed in
front of our faces saying it was a
close-up and then shibata's show fear
anger joy despair and I quickly learned
to how to get maybe a laugh or two out
of my fellow students and then it dawned
on me that if I was seriously going to
have a career in movies the wisest thing
was to do absolutely nothing at all and
that is more or less what I've done
since then
I feel very fraudulent taking this but
not letting any expression pass over my
face I I I thank you most sincerely for
the warmth of your reception and your
great kindness and to Dustin again and
I'm grabbing this while the goings good
thank you